各位同学大家好,欢迎来到隐私计算线上穆克第三期
本节课是库塞API的相关概念和场景实践
我是本节课程的主讲人李异长
本节课程将在之前穆克课程的技术上
以视频制作时的最新库塞版本为准
为大家讲解,通过库塞API搭建隐私计算项目
并执行隐私计算任务的流程
本节课程将会有以下四个部分组成
库塞API是什么,库塞API领域实体
库塞API使用实践指南
以及最重要的演示环节
首先让我们来看什么是库塞API
库塞API是库塞对外
提供隐私计算任务编排能力的入口
在隐与开源技术站中
库塞是其中的框架层
负责提供对secret flow
secco等隐情的集成
并提供了隐私计算的参与方
所需要执行的任务编排
网络打通的功能
极大地降低了产品使用者
平台集成者对隐与技术站的使用门槛
具体来看
库塞框架所在的调度层
由库塞和库塞隐外两部分组成
库塞隐外是在开源的隐外基础上
添加了库塞所需要的一些
网络概念的调整而来
库塞不仅包括了库塞隐外
也对刚才所提到的算法层的引擎
中的各种实体概念
做了进一步的封装
比如不同引擎所需要使用的数据
他们所需要开放的端口
所需要的配置信息等等
这些概念都将会通过库塞API
来进一步进行使用和管理
以提供给用户更好的使用体验
实际上产品层的库塞Secret Pied
就是在库塞API的基础上进一步开发得来
具体来说
库塞API所管理的领域实体
可以分为如下的级类
节点管理 节点路由管理
数据员管理 数据管理
数据授权管理 任务管理
模型部署和其他的一些功能
我们可以看到
大部分的功能都提供了
创建 删除 更新 查询和批量查询的功能
任务管理相对特殊
在后面将会详细的介绍
首先让我们来看
库塞API中的领域实体
节点是库塞对隐私计算节点的一种抽象
它可以是隐私计算合作中的一方
但并不一定只有一个节点
也可能是某一方向的多的副本节点
库塞中的大多数概念都需要依赖于节点
比如数据员 数据授权
节点的作模式主要有两种
一种是中心化的模式
也就是左下方的这张图
另一种是P2P的模式
是右下方的这张图片
在中心化的模式中
负责隐私计算任务的是Light节点
并且假定多个节点都信任一个
共同的控制面Master节点
P2P模式则是将所有的节点都视为
Master加Light的模式
也就是Autonomy节点
在这个模式下
Autonomy节点具备了Master和Light的全部功能
多个节点之间都是通过节点路由
完成网络的连接和身份的认证
在中心化组网的模式下
我们不仅需要创建Light之间的路由
也需要创建Light和Master之间的路由
而在P2P组网模式之下
只需要直接创建两个
Autonomy节点之间的路由即可
数据管理方面
库塞有三个重要的组成部分
数据 数据员和数据授权
数据 读面Data是指
隐私计算任务的输入或者是输出
可能是结构化的
也可能是非结构化的
如右图所示
他们可能是数据表 模型 预处理规则等等
库塞将会负责存储
读面Data的原信息
比如这些数据的数据员定义
对于结构化数据来说
还将会详细的记录各个列的信息
便于后续引擎去处理使用
而数据员 读面DataSource中
存储的则是读面Data
所代表的底层原始数据的存储方式
库塞目前已经支持了多种数据员
包括本地磁盘、OSS、ODPS等等
这些数据员的账号密码
连接地址都会存储在数据员中
在有了数据之后
为了进行多方隐私计算任务
我们还需要对这些数据进行授权
也就是将本方所属的数据的
原信息共享给相关的合作方
比如共享压门表的列信息
以便双方在配置具体的隐私计算任务时
明确使用其中的某些列作为ID
某些列作为特征
在节点网络数据都准备完毕的情况下
让我们来看看任务
库塞目前有Task,Job和Deployment的三种实体
其中库塞Task是库塞最小利度的调子单元
库塞Job则是若干个库塞Task
组成的一个有向无关图
如右头所示
库塞Task和库塞Job
主要是针对一次性运行的训练任务
定时任务
而库塞Deployment则是针对需要长时间存在的任务
比如一个联合预测服务
在配置了库塞Deployment之后
库塞将会按照其中的配置
在各个参与方下部署具体的服务
一同完成一个隐私计算相关的服务任务
库塞API相关的领域实体还有一些内容
包括应用镜像
应用配置
预置以及健康监测
前面我们讲了一下库塞API的基本介绍和领域实体
并且说明了领域实体之间的关系
我们再介绍一下库塞API使用中的主要流程
大致分为环境准备 数据准备和任务执行这三个部分
在环境准备阶段我们主要有三个步骤
分别是创建节点部署节点
以及创建节点路由
在数据准备阶段
我们需要创建数据员
创建具体的图面data
以及创建节点之间的一个数据授权
完成了这两步之后
我们就可以发现两个节点之间
他们可以看到对方的一个状态
并且能够看到对方授权过来的数据
然后我们就可以根据自己的需要
执行最后一步也就是任务执行
在这一步
你可以选择创建库塞罩
也可以选择库塞deployment
来执行一个长时间运行的服务
其中中心化模式下的一个环境准备
需要我们至少创建三个节点
一个master节点和两个light节点
在分别部署了各个节点之后
我们再去配置他们之间的节点路由
将light到master和light
之间的节点的网络打通
这里可以看到一个基本的环境准备的一个顺序
P2P模式则需要我们配置至少两个节点
并且配置他们之间的节点路由
在右侧我贴出了库塞API
在创建节点请求这方面的字段
可以看到在中心化模式
或者是P2P模式中
有部分的字段是有一定区别的
在准备好节点之后
我们就可以做数据的准备了
数据准备一般分为三个步骤
也就是创建数据员
准备数据
以及创建数据授权这三步
其中创建数据员是可以选择的一个步骤
在默认的情况下
本地也会存在一个数据员
另外我们在库塞的部署包里
也提供了一些创建样历数据员
创建样历数据
以及创建样历授权的这样一些脚本
可以方便大家快速的上手
使用API执行任务
则有以下的一些主要流程
它们分别是配置任务提交任务
执行任务监听任务状态
查看任务结果
查看任务日制
在监听任务状态阶段
库塞API提供了服务端推送的能力
用户可以用相关的
API监听服务端推送的信息
在任务结束或者是失败的时候
用户也可以通过库塞API来查看结果
和任务日制
接下来是这次课程的演示环节
本次演示使用的是
库塞V0.15.0 B0
这个版本
全体所需的Linux docker等要求
可以在库塞的官网中进行查看
我将以官网中提供的
各种GDP请求样历为主
完成一次从搭建节点
配置路由 创建数据 配置授权
创建样历任务
监听任务状态
查看任务日制的一个完整流程
这里额外提到一句
我们所推出的库塞Diagnose整段工具
这个整段工具
可以用于检测双方节点的网络
是否符合通信条件
这些网络当前的一些问题的更因
它含在检查项目
包括但不限于带宽 传输延迟
网关的最大请求包体大小的一个配置
包括网关缓冲配置和网关的超时配置
他们的使用场景也比较明确
就是在我们部署完成之后
可在实际执行算法作业前
对自己的网络状况进行个检查
以大概了解网络的一个带宽
和传输延迟情况
另外在执行算法作业失败时
或者是配置网络出现问题的时候
也可以用这个工具
对双方的网络环境进行一个诊断和定位
来排除或者是尽量解决网络环境的一些因素
这是我们本节课程的一个演示环节
在这个演示环境内
我将会使用准备到的这些脚本
去为大家演示一个任务
从节点的组件
到最后的一个查询日这样的一个过程
当然这个脚本主要就是
来自于官网的库赛API中的一些相关的描述
大家可以来官网查看
或者随时暂停查看我在视频中的相关脚本
首先是为大家隐藏了
在素质机上搭建两个刀柯人气的这样的一个过程
今天我们使用的是一个P2P的这样的一个模式
点对点搭建了ISC和BOB这样两个容器
第一步就是我们在ISC容器内去执行
添加BOB这样一个Domain的这样一个过程
在这个功能中我们要注意的是
如果使用API的方式
那么在SERT的这个自断里
我们需要使用的是BOB的一个
经过Base64编码的这样一个CRT文件
我们可以在这里面去做一个执行
那么同样可以在BOB内去执行这个过程
当然您在使用的这个请求的功能中
注意替换在SERT中的相关的一个过程
我们可以通过相关的这个
Domain的一些查询的API去查看
是否添加成功
之后我们就需要为两个容器去做一个
Domain Routes的一个创建
这里可以去参考官方文道中
关于Domain Routes的一些
自断的一些详细的一些描述
因为Domain Routes相对来说还是比较复杂的
也可以去阅读这个库杀概念中
关于Domain Routes的这一篇文章
除了基础的这样一个配置
其实Domain Routes还有更多进阶的功能
包括节点之间的转发
以及包括使用这个反向隧道这些能力
在Domain Routes中都会有一定的支持
好 接下来让我们创建这个Domain Routes
同样的在BOB这一侧也需要创建Domain Routes
我们可以通过库不肯之后去快速的去查看CDR
当然了我们的库杀API本身也是提供这种支持的
比如这里是一个查询以BOB为起点
以Alice为终点的这样一个路由
在BOB上查询
我们会看到它的状态是成功
这表明我们这个方向的路由已经配置成功了
你也可以再去Alice上去查看另外的一个方向
当然这里我们可以用库不肯之后去快速的做一个查看
它的Reddy这一行已经是一个处的一个状态
然后我们需要去为整个任务去准备一些数据
这里我直接在素质机上用我们库杀
镜像内本身就带有的一些样率数据做一个测试
首先把这个数据用Docker的脚本
去把它拷贝到容器的内部
BOB这次也是需要的
接下来就可以在Alice内创建我们刚才所提到的库杀独立data
其实这里我们可以看到
在容器内你应该已经能看到一个Alice.csv了
这是一个样率数据
在所有的库杀的一个镜像包里都可以找到这样一个内容
根据它里面各种列的信息
我们可以创建这样一个独立data
同样的在BOB这一侧也可以创建一个
当然我们的样率数据Alice.csv和BOB.csv是有一些区别的
在使用功能中你可以注意一下
之后是我们在Alice内的授权
因为我们刚才创建的独立data
它只是在每一个域的内部独立data是可建的
接下来我们就要为这两个table去做一个交叉的授权
在Alice内我们需要将AliceTable授权给BOB
我们可以看到这个授权是成功的
并且创建了一个DomainDataGround
另外可以在BOB内为Alice去做一个授权
也就是相反的把BOBtable授权给Alice
经过这两步之后我们已经可以在
任意一方查看到两个table了
这里我在BOB这边去查看一下
用的是DomainDataList这样一个接口
我们不仅可以看到BOBtable
也可以看到AliceTable
说明这个表已经被正确的授权了过来
当然BOB只能看到这个原信息
它的原始数据BOB是并不能看到的
当我们完成以上的所有准备工作之后
就可以开始创建任务
这个任务也是在官网中可以直接找到
这里我选择在Alice这边去做一个执行
提交任务之后
我们可以看到它会返回这个照片ID
这个时候我们就可以去监听这样一个照片
它是通过服务端推送的方式
不断的把后台更新的这样一个照片的情况
发送到享用里
因为我们现在的数据比较少
其实我们已经可以看到
它现在的party比如Alice这边
已经是一个suxade的一个状态
我们推出这个监听
可以直接来查看一下任务结果
可以看到里面的很多task都是一个成功的状态
目前来说如果您能在容器里
那其实也是可以通过GateKJ
也就是CudaJob和KT
也就是CudaTask的这样一个方式
去获得一个运行的结果
当然我们还是更推荐去使用API的一个方式
另外我们现在也提供去查看任务日治的这样一个能力
在这里我们可以看到其实
CudaTask有Job PSI和Job Split这两个
我可以通过调用LogTask Core的一个形式
去查看它的一个日治
比如说这里我选择查看Job PSI的日治
它打印的就是Job PSI这个引擎
它在运行时的全部日治了
最后还在演示当中为大家展示一下
Cuda Diagonal Network
它需要两个参数
当然还有更多的
我们可以去看它的文档
这个实用工具
其实它是用来帮助大家定位Cuda部署
和Cuda所遇到的一些网络问题
它比较经典的应用场合
就是当我们遇到一些算子执行的速度过慢
或者是中间出现一些丢包的情况的时候
我们可以用它来做一个排场
好的 今天的演示
主要的内容基本就到这里
我们所有的Cuda API
都可以在官方文档中找到
您在查语的时候
只需要注意一下自己所使用的这样一个版本
还有很多的内容
限于篇幅在这里就不再展开了
Cuda API
实际上现在还有包括创建Serving
创建App Image
还有为节点应用去做一些加密的配置
为了区分
我们会有一个单独叫Datamash API
Datamash是为引擎所服务的一个
用来读取存储数据的这样一个 API
正常来说
我们如果直接使用Cuda的情况下
是不需要考虑这个部分的 API的
这个主要是给引擎这些应用来使用
接下来为大家演示的是
Cuda API中关于Dumain Root
的一些进阶的一些配置方式
首先Dumain Root
在进阶这方面的用法一共有两个
一个是节点转发
另一个是反向隧道
这个在Cuda概念的Dumain Root的
这一个页面中有一个详细的展示
在Cuda API配置Dumain Root的时候
其实主要的内容
依然是CreateDumain Root Request
只不过其中的一些自断
根据我们的需要去做一些添写
那么这里我为大家演示的是
Alice和Bob之间通过
开入转发进行一个通信
首先是需要我们去准备
一个Carol这样一个点对点的容器
但是并不一定需要是
点对点的一个模式
只不过是因为我沿用了
刚才Alice和Bob之间的
这种一个组网方式
需要我们提前的准备好
Alice和Carol
Bob和Carol之间的
一个正常的连接
这里可以看到
其实我已经提前
完成这个方面的准备
并且把刚刚的Alice和Bob之间的
连接去做了一个断开
也就是说现在Alice和Bob
无法像之前一样
正常的去执行一个
隐私计算任务了
他们两个之间的路由
已经断开了
接下来呢
就需要用我们
转发的这种
DomainRoute的一个方式
为Alice和Bob之间
去做一个通信
这里的配置
变工主要就是
在Transit的这个自断
这里我们需要添写
Transit的Method
为ThirdDomain
然后它的DomainID为Carol
也就是说
我们从Alice到Bob这样一条路由
是通过Carol去进行转发的
这个配置
需要在Alice这边
去进行一个请求
那么同样的
相反的方向
从Bob到Alice的这样一个路由
也是要经过Carol
去做一个转发
在配置完成这个之后
我们可以再次去
查看DomainRoute的一个状态
可以发现
现在DomainRoute
又都恢复正常了
只不过
这个时候
Alice和Bob之间
其实是通过Carol
才能完成的通信
如果这个时候
我们重新运行
刚才的CousaJob
它的Alice和Bob之间
仍然是可以完成
隐私机的任务的
和不经过跳转
是表现是一样的
这就是
DomainRoute
进阶的一个省方式
那在我们已经完成
Alice经Carol
转发到Bob通讯的
这样的一个记录上
来为大家继续
演示一下
在Cousa中
如何去使用Serbian
去管理一些
常驻的服务
比如说SecretFlowSerbian
Serbian的底层实现的
就是之前
我们所提到的
Cousa Deployment
它会在Cousa内部
会作为一个常驻的
一个后台服务的
一个形式
在指南这里
有一个比较详细的
如何使用CousaEPI
运行一个Serbian
这样一个教程
我们可以
按照这个去
做一个执行
首先
组网
这里就不需要再执行了
我们已经完成了
这样一个搭建
接下来需要
我们做的就是
从这个准备
开始
我们可以来
调转过来
参考一下
SecretFlowSerbian
所提供的APP
Image
注意使用最新的
这个版本
在这里
它是一个压谋形式的
这个配置中
主要是给出了
它的一些
服务中用到的
一些配置模板
以及它部署
时候的
一些具体的
参数
我们可以用
APPImage
这个压谋
直接的
当然
也可以使用
我们刚才所提到的
在这个PUSA API中
所提供的APPImage
接口
相关的一些
创建更新的能力
但是这个接口
是要求我们
把输入
准备为JSON
这样的一个格式
在这里
演示
我就使用更为
减半的方式
直接创建
这样一个压谋文件
可以看到
我这里
已经完成了
这样的一个准备
并且使用的是
国内的一个镜像
可以加快它的
一个创建速度
是在多台机器上
都要部署的
这样的一个联合预测
所以我们需要在
iList和Bob上
都准备这样的一个环境
好的
接下来
我们就可以准备
提交我们的
服务的一些
具体的一些参数了
调用的接口
就是Serbincorate
因为我们使用的是
点的点模式
所以我们需要在
iList和Bob上这两边
都去提交这样的
一个请求
两份请求
只有这个initiator
这里
在这里
会稍微做一个修改
好
完成这样一部创建
我们可以在
任何一个机器上
去查看一下
Couple Control Guide
一下Corsa deployment
正如我刚才所说
这里有一个拼写错误
这我刚才所说
Serbincorate的底层
就是通过Corsa deployment的
实现
它会成为一个
常驻的服务
接下来
我们可以用
Serbincorate提供的
具体的接口
去查看它服务
运行状态的一个想象
在任意的节点都可以
当我们在iList上
去调用这个请求的时候
可以发现
现在我们的整个服务
它的total parties
一共有两方
并且available parties
也是两方
这就说明
我们在iList和Bob
这两侧的Serbincorate
都已经部署成功了
在确认这一点之后
我们就可以
具体的去发动一个请求
让它去做一个预测
到底我也是
继续选择在iList这边
去调用
可以看到整个服务
是能够执行一个
正常的返回
因为实际上
Serbincorate是需要
两个机器同时工作的
那么如果这个时候
我们用接口
比如说把Bob上面的Serbincorate
给它删除
这个时候
再去iList上
执行刚才的请求
会发现它已经
开始爆错了
那么我们把iList这边
也删除
然后可以再来看一下
Corsa deployment的
一个情况
会发现 deployment
也已经被Corsa
进行了回收
那么更多
详细的关于Serbincorate
部署的一些细节
还是可以在
Corsa API这个页面
去做一个查看
包括它的一些更新
包括它的这个
批量的查询
好 关于Serbincorate
这边的演示就到这里
在演示环节之后
相信大家对
Corsa API的使用和
相关概念
已经有了基本的了解
Corsa社区
一直在活跃的开发中
欢迎大家
积极的体验使用
并参与
去发布的各类任务
更多详细信息
大家可以随时
访问Corsa的官网
不过要注意
您所使用的版本
和官网中
您所查看的版本
相对应
感谢大家的聆听
这节课程就到此结束了
我们下次再见